hey guys this is going to be my legends
of tomorrow arrow video combined just
because there's so much stuff going on
they just announced a Batgirl movie from
Joss Whedon while I was finishing this
it's crazy if you're new to the channel
I do DC and Marvel videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave all your suggestions for bonus
videos and stuff you guys want to talk
about we're almost done with legends of
tomorrow this season both it and arrow
had been vastly better than they were
last season so I'm going to start with
legends of tomorrow because more people
were asking about that that the arrow
episode was also great so I'll talk
about that
we'll see if I can finish this in under
10 minutes we'll say about five minutes
or so for legends of tomorrow then five
minutes for arrow stuff so the fun of
this episode is in seeing the Legion of
Doom get their big win
it would have been crap if they didn't I
would have been so mad because they
hyped it all season long the victory of
the reverse-flash just standing tall the
only thing that made me really mad about
this though is the trophy case the
damian darhk-- has with all of the
heroes masks like they explained it's
been about a year so at some point here
II killed all of the people in Star City
he killed all the people in Central City
team arrow team flash completely gone
with the exception of the Legends
characters that he's turned into his own
private evil Charlie's Angels
so vixen and Sara were a ton of fun in
this episode I totally loved the black
leather getup
how can you not love that in the even
killed a superhero version of felicity
smoak so half of you are probably really
happy that she got to wear a costume in
the other half of you that really hate
the character are probably stoked that
she died so if you look at her costume
they put concept art of it up I totally
thought that she was going to be a
version of spoiler the Stephanie Brown
character from the Batman comics but
they just called her by her regular name
it was kind of a letdown but that might
be because they're not allowed to use
that Batman character name I don't think
that spoiler is ever going to show up on
any of the DC TV shows they might use
Stephanie brown somewhere but she's a
Batman character those tend to be more
off limits than the other comic book
characters there are a whole bunch of
Easter eggs in his office that go beyond
the trophy case
remember the idol from arrow season 4
maybe some of you skipped arrow season 4
he has magic it's sort of like his totem
like vixen has a totem of her own he
draws it from the souls of dead people
it sort of like sucks up the energy from
Dead Souls
so during arrow season 4 they busted it
the
took his power away he's got it back now
and he uses it Darth Vader style force
choking her all over the place moving
down the list as you would imagine
Malcolm Merlyn totally brought back his
wife which we've actually never really
seen on the show they've addressed her
in a pretty big way in the first couple
of seasons like he killed brick brick is
the character that Benny Jones played
during season 3 Merlyn killed him in
revenge for the death of his wife
because she died in the glades at a
hospital that she was working at so he
brought Tommy back but of course they're
not around because Colin Donald's busy
on another TV show kind of a bummer in
the way they cut around the really big
things that you wanted to see because
you know we get to the reverse-flash
who's taken over STAR Labs like he says
he really missed working with Caitlin
and Cisco on a team but in this timeline
you can see what he's done he's turned
himself into someone that everybody
loves he's a super genius he solved all
the world's biggest problems everybody
treats him like a god kisses his ass or
is terrified of him and he's got the
black flash in a containment unit like
they would put one of the metas in the
pipeline prison so a lot of you're like
hey wait a minute hold the phone why is
the black flash still around wouldn't he
use the spear of destiny to get rid of
it well there are two reasons for that
one is because if you keep an attack dog
around and you put it in the cage and
there's a person who is afraid of the
attack dog that nobody else can take
down how do you take care of that person
you can totally find a way to release
the attack dog in what a coincidence
that that attack dog has speed force
powers and wants to devour this time
aberration so the amazing coincidence
that the black flash just happens to be
10 feet away from where the reverse
flash works every day just means that
they're going to bring that back around
so just expect him to break out of that
case somehow maybe somebody will help
him escape hands-down biggest thing I
was upset about though is that in all
this victory you don't get to see the
reverse slash kill Barry Allen and make
it stick without erasing himself from
the timeline that was the whole reason
he killed his mother because he couldn't
kill Barry but just because of behind
the scenes stuff the actors being busy
filming other shows they couldn't do it
on screen so I was a little upset about
that but it's heavily implied the
reverse-flash helped kill Barry Allen
because in addition to being loved by
everyone as he is now that was at the
top of his to-do list
so moving down the list you have the
rogues they have their run of central
city in heatwave is like this is the
most boring thing ever captain cold is
totally not himself either he would also
get really bored by this too like they
love him it's almost like flashpoint
citizen cold where he's still kind of
evil but he's kind of in charge of the
city so I guess you could look at it as
an Easter Egg for that I love their
relationship but I felt like the twist
with their characters was the least
interesting like the reverse-flash is my
favorite character on the show so
naturally I was more interested in what
was going on with that storyline but
surprise surprise the Waverider is now
like a toy desk model on the reverse
flashes desk he walks by it every day so
that's probably part of the joke so rip
has got to find some way to escape maybe
he'll have something to do with
distracting the reverse-flash by
releasing the black flash and they'll be
able to repower the ship go back in time
and get back to the spear of destiny so
that they can fix everything I love the
fact that they turned the Hall of
Justice
from the flash into the Darth Vader
helmet from the animated show but I
think the biggest reason why this season
has been so much better than season 1
has been because of the dynamic that the
villains have won they're cooler
characters that you know from other
shows so you have a relationship with
them already like oh I know Malcolm
Merlyn from all those seasons on arrow I
know the reverse-flash because I read
about him in the comics I saw him on the
flash season 1 so the finale is titled
aruba there's going to be some crazy
twists I have a feeling they'll find a
way to resolve things fix the timeline
like fix reality but allow these
characters to continue to exist so that
they can come back in the next season
and be villains
hopefully they'll cycle the roster and
another person will join the Legion but
if you couldn't tell from all the
villain monologuing that the
reverse-flash did obviously that's all
going away they're totally going to hand
in his ass in the finale somehow it'll
be some big twist
vixen will come back because if she were
to die now then her daughter would never
be born and her granddaughter would
never become the vixen that we saw on
arrow season 4 so they'll go back in
time find a way to fix it before the
next episode of the flash and arrow so
if you're wondering why they didn't
address it on the other TV shows it's
because this is all happening in this
alternate reality so the other
characters wouldn't know about it either
and it's not meant to be like a big
three or four-way cross
so ver but now we got to talk about the
arrow episode Silence of the Lambs
Prometheus has been the best villain so
far it is a beautiful morning I love the
way they ended the episode so the whole
thing here is in turning the Bratva into
big villains maybe even for season 6
like maybe the Bratva KGB's can be one
of the big bads for season 6 but can we
talk about how Stephen Amell sold low
time Oliver he did such a good job I
could not tell if he was faking it it
was going to be some big twist but there
was no twist he definitely believed
everything that Prometheus told him but
the whole point of that was for Diggle
giving him the business later so you get
this big payoff where he says remember
when I was in prison you told me to come
back and be a vigilante again to atone
for what I did so you need to do that
now Oliver and you don't have to do it
alone
so it's sort of like this really low
point like guested a rock bottom before
he can start working his way back up so
we're kind of seeing the beginnings of a
new version of Green Arrow like green
arrow rebirth as it's happening in the
comics right now cagey beast also gave
him a version of that line to where he's
talking about not being dual identities
just always being the green arrow like
Batman definitely has two distinct
personalities he has Bruce Wayne in the
knee as Batman Batman is the normal
personality Bruce Wayne is meant to be
the mask is the other way around for
Clark Kent and Superman like people talk
about that Clark Kent is not the mask
Superman is the mass that he wears but
you may call the Batman arrow jokes
Oliver is like that he has the dark
version of himself that he's felt like
up to this point has been the true
version of him this whole crusade of
mine has just been an excuse to let me
do that so he's saying that everything
he's done the last couple of seasons has
been to allow him to fulfill that dark
desire that prometheus was getting him
to admit to so obviously that's all bull
crap as Diggle says like Diggle is the
voice of reason trying to slap some
sense into him and now that prometheus
has been outed to the police and is a
fugitive they can really go at it gloves
off which is why I love the twist at the
end where they given the evidence the
Adrian chase is prometheus and you're
like okay maybe he'll have some
workaround for this or some way to cheat
it or they'll lose the evidence but nope
they totally went for
so the remainder of the episodes will be
Prometheus just fully coming after
Oliver and now that the green arrow has
been almost exonerated he can actually
hit the streets again so Oliver can put
the costume back on and here's the cool
thing
so Katie Cassidy was confirmed as a
series regular for season six but she's
not coming back as Black Canary because
remember we have the new Black Canary
she's coming back as black siren but
because she's going to be a series
regular that's a big question as to how
she's going to fit into the team is she
going to be part of team arrow or if she
going to be a recurring villain hanging
out with whoever the big bads of season
six are going to be is this going to be
a resurgence of the Suicide Squad
because we have king shark and
prometheus will probably get thrown in
Argus eventually - in the actor that
played Captain Boomerang with teasing
that he might be coming back so it just
feels like there's a lot of Suicide
Squad things happening in the background
they're just all those people are
chilling out at Argus so it's like hey
if you have them in your back pocket why
don't you let them come out and have
some fun but there's still a whole bunch
of questions we have several episodes to
go so we'll get more clues about where
they're going with season six by the end
of the season it'll be a lot of fun so
let me know what did you guys think
about both of the episodes it was
totally solid legends of tomorrow I
can't wait to see what they do with the
finale I'm really excited about season
three I feel like I love the flash
characters more like I'm a bigger fan of
their comic book characters but what
Arrow's been doing has been so much more
solid than the other shows the last
couple of weeks but what's going to
happen next is is there was a whole
bunch of new Justice League footage in
Aquaman footage for the Aquaman movie it
would scream last night so I'll do a
breakdown of what that is they teased at
land who was from the new 52 he was the
original king of Atlantis so it sounds
like he's actually going to be in the
Aquaman movie Legion just at its finale
- so I'll try to do an explainer video
for that congratulations to the latest
flash ring giveaway winner nerd ninja
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round in
this video announce the winner when I
post that next Justice League video so
that should drop in the next couple of
hours while you wait for that you can
click here for brand new flash and you
can click here to learn about how Sony
and Marvel might not be sharing the
spider-man character after they gets
done with all of the spider-man Home
Coming movie
so it's not as bad as it sounds but
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys in the next
video